so uh the next uh
talk it's uh going to be from uh sudas
khalid
who works basically if it's a data
scientist at google
before that she was at amazon
she's also very active in a career
coaching
of younger data scientists and
particularly women so it's very nice
that
we have a talk from here in this pi data
one of the advantages basically of
having a virtual pi data conference is
that you have
speakers from uh other continents u.s in
that case
so i will give basically uh
the uh floor to uh sudes she can
share her screen and yeah
see her presentation all right
uh first of all sorry about that
everybody
it's the new world that we're living in
so we have to deal with all these
technical religious
glitches so thank you so much for being
patient and
um and just helping us just waiting and
letting us go through this
um so my talk today is going to be very
lightweight i know you have been
attending talks all day so i'm going to
make sure
i keep it very lightweight and as
engaging as possible
and i would like all of you to um
use the chat box uh feature to kind of
leave comments if you have questions
during the session
feel free to leave questions in the
comment section or in the q a section we
will address those towards the end
and i just want all of you to enjoy the
talk and just be engaging as much as you
can
all right so a little bit about myself
um
so my name is sanders khalid you can go
to the next slide
uh my name is khalid i am currently a
senior analytical lead
at google previously i was working at
amazon as a data scientist my current
work
involved in the core search area
where i worked on google search
advertisement space specifically
when i was at amazon a year ago i was
working on the eb testing
platform where i was supporting the
basically all the av testing
methodologies that was
being used by the retail as well as
alexa
prime music um video uh pretty much all
the teams that are present at amazon and
they were launching new features and
they were testing and before
launching they would test it and
depending on the a b test results we
will either launch the feature or not
watch the feature
could you go to the next slide please
um so uh besides that i
uh run a side business as a career coach
i am very
a big advocate of diversity and
inclusion initiatives i currently serve
on the board of two non-profits
um and i'm also facilitator for i am a
remarkable workshop
on my side like my hobbies are public
speaking
blogging and community building after
the session you can connect me on any of
these sessions
on any of these social media channels
all right so let's jump
right into our topic for today so um
i'm talking to all of you data people
and all of these smart people
um so you already know this that data is
the future
uh just to put some perspective to it um
there are 3.7 billion humans that are
currently using the internet
and um those humans have generated 40
trillion
gigabyte of data just in 2020
and 90 of the data was created just in
the last two years
and um what's more staggering is that
less than one percent of the data is
actually analyzed today
so when we are talking about when we're
saying that the data is the future
there is a lot more data out there that
is yet to be analyzed so when we say
data is the future
data is the future next slide please
so um we know that ai
and machine learning has been
revolutionary machine learning is
a science of discovering patterns and
finding relationships with dia it's
powerful
for creating personal lives and dynamic
experiences
and it has been revolutionary in many
fields including health care
education military one of my favorite
examples is that
machine learning and ai is currently
being used
for catching human traffic criminals
where
image-based ai programs are capturing
criminals using satellite images
of media's enforced laborers so when we
talk about that ai is changing our world
ai is truly changing our world for the
good
um and it has revolutionized many fields
and it continues to evolve
so um but that being said there are
biases
that are inherently present in the human
nature that
end up being translated into the data
and in the technology that we built
so before we jump into the next part of
my talk i want to do a small
exercise with all of you so feel free to
use your chat box
um to kind of type so could you please
go to the next slide
so what i want all of you to do is
imagine a shoe just think of a shoe and
a type of a shoe a color a type whatever
comes to your mind just think of it
and you can either type it in your chat
box or
you can just keep it to yourself which
is fine so i'll
give you a few seconds to think about it
all right so um
let's go to the next slide so how many
of you
thought of this shoe and this color
a sneaker
a running shoe next slide
maybe a business casual shoe a loafer
how many of you thought of this show of
hands
next one how many of you thought of this
that's pretty so next slide
so the idea is that all of us
probably thought of a different shoe and
we may not even
know it but we all have bias toward one
shoe or another
and they just come into our minds mind's
eyes first
now imagine that you are building a ml
model that can recognize shoes
you may expose your your your
perception of issue whatever comes to
your mind in your bias in the model
and that's how biases happen in machine
learning
because with machine learning you show a
model many examples and those examples
are often labeled
human edit descriptors and if those
labels have biases built in
then that bias gets engineered into the
machine learning models
so it's really important to discover
those biases
early and figure out how to mitigate an
effects
as you are developing your machine
learning models
let's go to next
so um we know that we all know we have
all heard this that ai can be biased
and when ai and supercomputers and
machine learning was introduced first
many people thought that this is going
to revolutionize because
it's going to remove all unfairness in
the world
but somehow we overlook the fact that
these ai models and algorithms
are created by humans and humans are
inherently biased
these biases can be explicit or implicit
i also know that known as unconscious
bias
when algorithms are built many decisions
are taken by human that decide what
algorithms will do
and that's how the biases get introduced
into the technology that we do end up
building
so let's talk about some real world
examples now
um where ai has actually
impacted the real lives of people
through its biases
um there is a big bias present in a lot
of the hiring systems
that are out there there was a study
done by
um harvard business review along with
northeastern university and usc
and they found that the jobs
the ads on facebook for jobs for
touchdown jobs
were targeting and they were biased for
example
85 of the cashier jobs were targeted
toward women
and 75 percent of the taxi driver jobs
were targeted toward black and this is a
case
of bias without human intervention
and such recommendation systems are
purpose built to find and replicate
pattern in user behavior updating
predictions dynamically as employers and
job seekers
interact there are systems out there
that
know learn from like for example if a
system is learning from recruiters
behavior so if a system that notices
recruiters happen to interact
more frequently with white men it may
well
find proxies for those characteristics
such as
like being named as jared type names as
shattered or playing high school
lacrosse
and replicate that pattern this sort of
adverse effect
can impact can happen without explicit
instructions and worse without even
realizing
and these tools may not always be
dystopian headlines
but they play a critical role in
determining who has access to the hiring
process and another example is the top
five resume ai model
that was used by amazon a while back
um and it turns out that it biases
against women so what the model was
actually doing it was looking at 100
resume hundreds of resumes
and from those hundreds of resumes it
was picking up
top five resumes and a lot of the hiding
managers
were starting to use um
use this rather than into the system to
kind of like find the top
five people and um interview them so
what ended up happening
is that um the top five resumes ended up
taking
specific characteristics that were
that were based on the historical data
that was already present because there
were a lot of
men in the jobs they ended up
using the historical indicators to kind
of
only pick the top resumes of men and it
ended up leaving a lot of women now
and now amazon has never confirmed this
but they were using a third-party tool
they
did end up they did end up stop using
that uh
that tool eventually but they have never
confirmed this
um from there and this is another
company called butters who have done the
study and figured this out
on their own and these target
these biases that are present in the
recruiting systems in the hiring system
they eventually does end up translate
translating into the
equities that exist in the workplace
and we don't see many examples of it
because that information does not get
released
openly so another example
that um next slide please um so this you
may or may not have heard before
um another study found that
this absolutely done by georgia
institute of technology
and they found that um self-driving cars
are more likely to crash
in dark skinned pedestrians
now this is just um just like when i
heard this
before the first time i was like wow why
could how could this be happening like
this is such a basic
thing right um but it is
this is what exactly what they found so
what they actually did
they looked at a large data set of
images containing
contained pedestrians they divided up
the people
using fitzpatrick skill a system
classifying human skin tones from light
to dark
and the researchers then analyzed how
often the models correctly detected
presence of people in the light skin
tone versus
how often they got it right for people
in the dark skin tone group
detection was five percentage point less
accurate on average for the dark-skinned
wrong people
and the disparity persisted even when
researchers controlled for variables
such as
time of the day in images or
occasionally abstracting view of the
pedestrians so and now
another caveat here is that this is a
third-party study
this this study that i'm referring to it
has not been
uh peer reviewed and it's not using the
actual model that is used by the
self-driving cars
because that model both that algorithm
will never be released to the public
this is another third party uh a third
party that is conducting this study on
their own
building up a similar model
as self-driving cars to kind of figure
out what exactly is happening
um all right so why so now you might be
wondering like why why would this be
happening
i'm sure like already some of you have
thought about ideas why this might be
happening feel free to write them in the
chat box
um so some hypothesis is that that the
training
was done the training on the ml model
was done on the lighter skin toned
people so basically the data that they
had was mainly
including people of lighter skin tone
and
let's say in cases where they maybe they
did have dark skin tone people
the model didn't place enough weight on
learning from those very few examples
so those could be some of the reasons
that are possibly
uh possibly leading to this
this implications that we're seeing in
the
in the model results
so let's go to the next slide please
so now we're talking about we talked
about the hiding
um we talked about the soldering card
now this one
i if if i were to rank all of them i
think this one is the catastrophic
and most of that specific example all
because it has
implications um that are impacting
somebody's
life and you probably have already heard
about this because this is a very
uh popular controversial um model that
is already out there and people have
talked about it before
so for those of you don't know is
basically compass
is a tool that assigns scores from one
to ten
that indicate how likely or somebody is
to reoffend
based on 100 factors and this is used
for people
when they the judges are trying to in
the criminal system when judges are
trying to figure out what is the verdict
what is the length of the time the
person would stay in jail
and they used hundred factors the model
uses 100 factors including age sex
criminal history
not the race race is not used and these
scores profoundly affect dependents
lives and defendants who are defined as
medium to high risk with scores 5 to 10
are more likely to be detained while
debating
trial than our low risk defendants with
scores one before
and pro republic pro publica which is
another
company uh they collected data on campus
scores for more than 10
000 people that were arrested in florida
and they checked to see
how many of these charges char how many
of these people who were charged
with further crimes within two years how
many people did actually the offend base
compared to these scores
so pro publica found that among the
defendants who ultimately did not
reoffend
blacks were more than twice as likely as
whites to be classified as medium or
high risk
42 percent versus 22
and this is a big number and the number
itself is huge
but the implications itself are even
later because
if you are their skin tone and this is
the model that is being used
um to kind of score you the chances are
you will end up spending more time in
jail than your bike here
um now to be truly fair the judge should
have also
used um the score as well as
when they when they see the scores and
when they see the person who is in front
of that they should have also seen the
skin color
and their race when interpreting these
results now
compass did come back and say that their
model is actually
doing what they're supposed to do and
it's actually completely fair
and now going further back maybe what's
happening is actually the underlying
data that is by us in itself
that kind of is introducing the model to
do whatever it is doing now
all right let's go to the next slide
so now you all must be asking can this
be solved
um
okay um let's go to the next slide
please
so i wish i had a magic bullet answer to
this
but i don't um the main
and the only way we can solve this is
using a human-centered approach i
believe us
and people in this room are powerful
because we have
access to the data we are the people
making those models we are the people
making taking decisions for these
when these models are being built and
the only way to solve this
is using a human-centered approach where
we're educating the users
and the creators so we are the as a
creator are getting educated of issues
like these and
unconscious biases that all of us tend
to have are not
translating into the work that we are
doing
and creators and users who are actually
using these models
are actually aware of that these
models can eventually be biased um
for example the campus example where i
gave where i said the judge should also
be looking at the score but also as well
as the person's race and be
mindful that they couldn't be inherently
biased in there
and again like um building diverse and
inclusive teams
in the product life cycle is going to
get us there
when we have diversity of ideas when we
are inclusive of
everybody who the product and model is
being built for
we can take all um edge cases and
all um on all groups into consideration
when we're building these models
um and especially like i know like as a
business
making money is the first thing but as
humans we should be more morally and
ethically responsible
when we are putting a technology out
there
and those can all become through
education and through ethics and
being like more self-aware and more
being more aware of
our own unconscious biases and the last
but not the least is the feedback loop
is
create a feedback loop once you have
built something it's in the production
make sure that you are evaluating it
again
make sure that you have the fairness
metrics that you are measuring not just
one multiple of them to evaluate how
your model is performing against
different groups
different use cases um so that way you
kind of have like a more
um collective approach to not just
building something but also making sure
that it's doing
the the thing that you build is doing
what it's supposed to do
and with that um could you please go to
the next slide
and with that that would be end of my
presentation
um we all know that um inequities
do exist humans tend to be biased and
those biases
do under translating into the work that
we do
and the technology that we build ai is
biased because humans are biased we
we collectively can solve this by being
educated
being inclusive building inclusive teams
and putting
putting ethics and social responsibility
at the forefront
and with that thank you so much for your
time
and i would open the floor for questions
so uh thanks sudas for the very
interesting talk
already there is a big discussion about
it in
discord we have some questions for the
from the panel that i would like to ask
you
uh the first one it's about basically
if the buyers come from people who do
the analysis
if the bias is in the data set also
someone can save the bias it's
really it's related to the model to the
models or the interpretation that you're
doing
afterwards would you like uh to make a
comment about
the biases in a different step of the
machine learning process
i'm sorry i lost you at the last part
what did you say okay
so if you would like to comment uh it's
the question
on the biases of uh on the different
steps of the machine learning process
basically
are the human bias the data set bias and
the machine learning algorithm biases
the interpretation biases that we might
have these kinds of things
yeah so exactly as you said there are
many biases
that can be used introduced throughout
the whole machinery link building cycle
and i know like my talk specifically
focused on like the underlying
bias in the data that exists itself and
the human bias that can kind of amplify
it even further
um but yeah there are like different
biases that could be introduced
beyond that and i know it's like so much
easier to kind of figure out
in a label data set where things are
labeled and we can easily say
like figure out like through uh analysis
that
maybe this biases that is present in
this
data and it's like i i can't imagine
like this like more
like more challenging when we're working
with like unlabeled data and like
uh not supervised learning and
um so i think it all comes down to like
being more aware and be making it part
of the process
um when of like our machine learning
model
building process where we are like kind
of evaluating biases
in each step not just at the start but
also as well
at the end and eventually when it's
launched as well we're kind of like
going back again and looking at it again
and trying to see like if there are
additional biases because
maybe it's because human uh behavior is
because introduced from human behavior
something else that is going on that is
we did not expect to happen
okay thanks uh we have another question
from
zainab uh does human center approach
means that we need
more more post-processing or manual
efforts
i think we need more post and
pre-processing
um so pre-processing in terms of like
just understanding the data set that we
have
how are we feature engineering what
features are we including
in our data set and the data set that we
have what does it look like
and um i think this is somewhat we're
already
doing to some extent but i think what we
can do better is more
post-processing and it doesn't have to
be manual efforts i mean it could start
with like
some prototypes but eventually if we can
automate
i think that would be an ideal solution
but i obviously like more adding more
steps
in the pre and post processing and those
would be done like through like
developing fairness metrics
where you are evaluating the fairness of
your model through
some kpis that you have developed along
the way